[Music]
oh
this is the orinoco belt the heart of
venezuela's oil reserve venezuela is the
first country in the world for the
amount of oil deposits here gasoline is
the cheapest in the world in dollar a
gallon is about 0.095 cents basically
the government in venezuela pays people
to drive
italy why won't you never copy from the
best ones however the contradiction is
that today venezuela is out of gasoline
and the nearly 30 million citizens are
forced to push cars by hand and to stand
in line for hours if not days while not
having gone through a war or natural
disaster venezuela has been torn apart
by a severe humanitarian and economic
crisis for years pharmacies without
medicines empty supermarkets constant
blackouts shortages of drinking water
lines of citizens waiting to receive one
single box of food per month from the
government a lawless state in the hands
of drug trafficking clans and one of the
worst cases of inflation in history not
so many months ago at sixty thousand
fifty hundred percent where to have one
single dollar in your pocket you'd need
to own this whole amount of believer all
of this is venezuela today a gallon of
milk in the us is two dollars thirty
cents correct me if i'm wrong google
said so therefore in venezuela you'd
need this amount of believer i don't
even know how to pronounce it this is
too much for those who are not native
english speakers like me venezuela
besides being the only nation with two
presidents one elected the maduro and
the other the self-proclaimed president
at interim guido is also the only nation
where a dollar can have two different
values for years the venezuelan
government has been distributing dollars
at a favorable exchange rate of 6.3
believer per 1 only to a small elite
entrepreneurs military and large
industrial groups for the other people
the rest of the population there's the
black market the black markets strongly
contested by the central government and
in 2016 one dollar was exchanged for one
thousand two hundred believers an
increase of five thousand percent per
year but venezuela wasn't always like
this it used to be a wealthy country the
richest in south america so
how did it fail well we can start off
with a mix of three factors the first
factor is the corruption of the various
local governments all of them from the
first to the latest regardless of
whether they were socialist or not and
above all their inability to properly
manage oil resources the second factor
has been the external interference an
example of all the american sanctions
that in recent years have only served
one purpose to make the population die
of hunger and disease and finally oil
the blessing and curse of this country
since chavez came to power in 2002 the
state oil company has cashed in over a
trillion dollars from oil sales just
think about it more than 13 times the
expenses of the marshall plan and yet
the nation is in ruins the paradox is
that three centuries from now when most
of the world's oil is gone venezuela
would still be able to extract it
venezuela teaches us a very important
lesson too much money if mismanaged can
even be more risky than not having any
money at all i can take this risk thanks
to oil in the 50s and 60s venezuela was
among the 20 richest countries worldwide
in terms of per capita income the state
provided cheap loans subsidies plenty of
jobs and free public services and
ensured that an overvalued currency the
bolivar made imported goods easily
accessible in those years everyone was
able to get anything without too much of
a trouble venezuela had all the typical
characteristics of a profitable state it
was a rentier state where the higher the
oil revenues were the fewer the
incentives to improve the national
industry were where is daddy mommy we're
here in the united states
and daddy is down here in venezuela but
by now he's down here where the lake
maracaibo oil fields are in venezuela
life changed on one exact day july 31st
1914 when a dark sticky liquid began to
come out of the ground at a rate of more
than 250 barrels per day it was the
caribbean oil company a branch of the
shell oil company that on that day made
a hole in the maracaibo field at that
time venezuela was a nation without a
minimum index of development and with a
population of 2 million inhabitants
entirely dedicated to agriculture the
only law was the word of president juan
vincente gomes for mr gomez oil was a
real boon annual oil production exploded
in the mid-20s from just over a million
barrels to 137 million making venezuela
second only to the united states by
granting crude oil concessions to all
the western companies that rushed to
venezuela by the time of his death in
1935 gomez had become one of the richest
men in latin america it was also thanks
to or because of him that venezuela saw
the rise of the militaries which were
financed with oil revenues it is thanks
to the goodwill of the venezuelan army
that maduro fears no rival when gomez
died the oil revenues accounted for
two-thirds of national income and more
than 90 percent of the country's exports
basically venezuela became the perfect
target of a peculiar phenomenon the
dutch disease economists know this
disease very well but oil transformed
the leaves of venezuelans to the point
of giving them unimaginable benefits in
just 20 years in 1952 when general
marcos paris hemantz obtained power with
a coup d'etat putting an end to the
democratic experiment of the triennoa
deco venezuela already looked like
another country this new period of shine
was represented by the first national
highway wanted by hemanet to connect the
capital caracas to the coastal city of
laguara venezuela's good fortune was to
have found the right hydrocarbon at the
right time globally the demand for oil
skyrocketed during the post-war economic
boom the middle east took care of the
rest pushing oil prices to record levels
the nationalization of the oil industry
by iran in 1951 and the overthrow of
muhammad musadak two years later as well
as the closure of the swiss canal by the
president of egypt nasser attracted
petrodollars to venezuela during the
years jimenez was in office until 1957.
no other country did better than
venezuela in terms of foreign capital
accumulation venezuela did even better
than west germany which at the time had
enjoyed the marshall plan subsidies
foreign investments in venezuela tripled
during the ximena's regime companies
were free to invest earn and return
their money without obstacles of any
kind the golden rule to follow was this
go ahead go go go ahead and do business
but don't get in the way of my
oppressive government signed mr jimenez
with petrodollars the cost of living in
venezuela reached extremely high levels
an american who in the 50s earned 1 000
a month today about 9 000 could barely
make ends meet he meant its ambitions
not only led to the nation's name being
changed from the united states of
venezuela to the republic of venezuela
but also promoted the creation of
state-owned companies in the mining
steel and petrochemical industries as
well as schools hospitals and homes for
the poor everything had to seem
up-to-date impressive and elegant to
attract foreign visitors skyscrapers
luxury hotels and villas sprouted up
like mushrooms in caracas while the
growth rate ended up averaging a plus
five percent per year the venezuelan gdp
per capita was for many years one of the
highest in south america and the
believer was the strongest and most
stable currency in the area those who
were poor didn't think twice to spend
all of their money on goods like air
conditioners designer clothes and cable
television that's where i called
priority very few chose the path of
saving money the rich people too the
best way was always to borrow money
buying the latest items seemed to be
always a necessity and as for the
president ximena the big deal with him
was
repression jails were full of political
opponents workers and students movements
had all been shut down and the military
came under the spotlight of popular
criticism the loss of prestige for the
military meant only one thing to get
humanity out of the way there was no
need for guns or bloodshed it was more
than enough to have an unfriendly chat
behind closed doors with the military in
january 58 ximena's and his family
packed their bags and around 3am boarded
a plane to the dominican republic their
departure was so rushed that upon
boarding humanity left behind a suitcase
with 2 million dollars in cash i wish i
was at the airport at the time anyway
the main issue for venezuela was the
dilemma of how to ensure political
stability the answer came in the form of
a pact known as pact de punto fijo an
agreement between the three main
venezuelan parties the social democrats
the christian democrats and the urd the
agreement led to the election of romulo
betancourt betancourt delegated the
diplomats juan pablo perez alfonso to
manage the national oil paris alfonso
would later define oil as the devil's
excrement paris knew full well how
mismanaged oil wealth could be
detrimental to an entire nation but he
also knew that venezuelans and not
foreign oil companies should control it
his concerns were not left to chance at
the time the seven sisters the world's
most powerful oil companies dominated
more than 80 percent of the crude oil
reserves globally to make things worse
the united states decided to limit oil
imports from venezuela so to favor
canadian and mexican crude paris alfonso
then proposed to saudi arabia kuwait
iran and iraq the idea of entering into
a private agreement a cartel and this is
briefly the story of how the opec was
created in 1960. with this move between
the 60s and 70s the country became known
as saudi venezuela from neighboring
colombia masses of citizens flocked to
venezuela's borders hinops of making a
new life that's sadly ironical because
today the situation is quite the
opposite according to the latest data
from the center for strategic
international studies a diaspora of
millions of venezuelans flee every day
from venezuela to colombia and ecuador
around the 4 000 people a day at the
time however caracas had become such a
fashionable destination that air france
operated the fast route to and from
paris in 1976 with a supersonic concord
jet meanwhile masses of people kept
migrating from farms to cities
agriculture was left behind but the
national demand for food was growing as
a result the government was forced to
import basic commodities to meet this
demand wheat corn rice basically
products that venezuela had been
producing domestically up to that point
with a broken farming industry the
venezuelan economy wasn't diversified
and strong enough to provide employment
for most people this generated an
increase in social spending which the
government had provided through
subsidies paychecks and public
administration jobs to middle and
low-income venezuelans the various
governments that have been in office
from betancourt to chavez all reasoned
in the same way venezuela could afford
to survive without taxing its citizens
we have oil so who freaking cares oil
removed political accountability
politicians used it to get the support
from their voters and voters used it as
an excuse to get subsidies and have a
living with it as this wasn't enough
paris doubled the state's payroll to
more than 300 000 employees in five
years and in addition it passed the law
prohibiting wrongful dismissal by all
those companies that unable to bear the
costs had no other option but to reduce
staff for this reason the most logical
choice for anyone who wanted to do
business in venezuela was to rely on
government subsidies and loans why
should i run a company with the risk of
expanding too much in terms of
production and personnel and then not
being able to fire people in case of
need banana republic this was the term
that for example the new york times
would use to define venezuela with the
establishment of the state oil company
pedebesia in 1983 the government finally
took steps to nationalize the oil
industry and put an end to most
concessions to foreign companies by the
end of that year venezuela finally took
possession of its golden goose however
destiny right in the middle of such an
important event ironically began to
present its bill in 1988 a global oil
surplus generated a contraction in
demand for crude oil this cut the price
of venezuelan oil from 35 dollars to 14
per barrel since they grew accustomed to
generous governments venezuelans still
continued to spend even despite their
declining salaries the crisis fell on
president luis herrera campaigns a
former journalist who would later be
remembered for stealing almost 6 billion
dollars from the state oil company
facing the lower inflow of money into
the country and the flight of foreign
capital campaigns tried to prevent the
disaster in the so-called black friday
of 1983 when it evaluated the purchasing
power of the believer by 75
well that's what i call black friday and
not like that fake black friday on that
same day any venezuelan with savings
immediately ran to exchange the believer
for any hard currency whether it was
dollar or not but the restrictions on
the circulation of money imposed by
campaigns blocked any attempts to make
capital flee overseas a feeling of
insecurity spread throughout the
population and shaped an oppressive
atmosphere of violence quite different
from the ease and well-being that had
dominated the last 30 to 40 years in
short venezuela found itself without
resources to pay for food imports
this was a major issue in a country
where little was produced and much was
consumed why breed cows when you could
import the best meat from argentina or
brazil why make things out of wood iron
and steel when you could buy them
cheaply from europe for years
venezuelans made the mistake of
believing that to be entrepreneurs it
was enough to import goods and resell
them at home at a higher prices people
in venezuela were used to the idea of
living in a rich nation that thanks to
oil could and should give them
everything citizens of caracas were
addicted to taking a plane and
vacationing in miami to go shopping
estabaratto damedos a cheap give me two
this was essentially their motto however
in 1989 bread toilet paper sugar milk
flour all basic necessities gradually
began to disappear from supermarket
shelves to reappear almost magically i'd
say on the black market so the venezuela
was so deep in debt that the government
was forced to use almost 40 cents of
every single dollar that he got from the
oil sales to pay off its loans it became
very clear that venezuela could no
longer afford giving free money to its
people
uncompromised
the government this time no longer
campaigns by the game paris cut public
spending such a move inevitably led to
widespread protests by thousands of
citizens throughout the country when in
february 1989 the paris government
announced an increase in gas prices the
entire city of caracas went to the
streets in a series of riots and mass
demonstrations that event would become
known in history as caracazo and was
just the beginning of the venezuelan
decline paris responded with the
suspension of civil rights and imposed
martial law for venezuelans paris became
the symbol of total corruption and
partially they were right selling
dollars at preferential rates had
motivated officials to steal in many
ways regarding paris we can say that the
apple never falls far from the tree in
1993 paris was charged and found guilty
of embezzling 17 million dollars from
the state's funds his conviction though
made it possible for hugo chavez to rise
to power six years later already 1993
when he was still an unknown army
paratrooper chavez had unsuccessfully
attempted a coup against paris but
having failed wasn't a problem for
chabitz venezuelans didn't care so much
that the military was once again
dictating the timing of a government
what really mattered to them was getting
a bit of welfare from that precious oil
which seemed to be out of their hands
now
patreon
and so chavez rose to fame by building
his reputation as a man who stood in
open opposition to a corrupt and dying
party but chavez guys is another chapter
in the history of venezuela we don't
have time to discuss about him right now
maybe in the future but for now i just
thank you very much for keeping me
company until the end i'll see you in
the next video bye